now I'm trying to figure out whether or
not this is the first live-action
adaptation of a manga that I've seen
might be a Lita battle angel to say that
I have been waiting for this movie for a
long time would be actually quite a
severe understatement I first heard that
James Cameron had gotten the rights to
make this as a movie and had begun work
on it back when I was in college so
we're talking about 15 years ago
ballpark so what so like I said been
waiting a long time and actually I got I
was really annoyed that the existence of
avatar for a while because he put this
movie on hold in order to start making
avatar then I was like great avatar is
done he'll make battle angel and then he
said I'm doing all these avatar sequels
and the reason we now have the movies II
step back to be producer and Robert
Rodriguez came on which could have gone
either way Robert Rodriguez is a
director who when he's on it can deliver
some really great stuff but his working
with more special effects heavy stuff
you're really kind of up and down like
Sin City came out pretty well but a lot
of the other stuff not so much so I was
excited I was nervous I had a lot of
very jumbled up feelings going to the
theater to see this and I liked it I
liked it quite a bit
overall I would rate it as a pretty good
now I do want to specify the way in
which is pretty good cuz when you say a
movie is pretty good that in my mind at
least that can be one of two things it
either means the whole thing just sort
of played at a level of oh all right or
it could be that there are some elements
that were really good but there were
other elements that weren't as good and
then it balances out about pretty good
this is the latter case so let's start
with what is really good and then the
reason why I'm quite
happy with the movie despite some of the
faults I'm gonna end up pointing out was
because what I love about a leader and I
think I'll just call it that because if
I try and do the full title I'll keep
getting mixed up as to whether I'm doing
it the order of the movie does it or the
manga does it cuz in the manga it's
battle angel leader the movie its ally
to battle angel I'm just gonna call it a
leader so with a leader
the reason that I love it is the
character dynamics by and large
particularly when it comes to Aleta and
IDO the characters who in this case are
played by Rosa Salazar and Kristoff
vaults and they're those characters and
their relationship is perfect
I mean Christoph Waltz was a great gift
because IDO is is the kind of character
who in the hands of the wrong actor
could come across as creepy and
Christoph Waltz never does you have
nothing but sympathy for him there's
humanity just kind of radiating off of
him and it it makes it work despite you
know I was a few clunky bits of dialogue
but that's that's an issue with the
writing not with his performance he is
he has a wonderful performance dynamic
with Aleta and he's he's just he's
really good but seriously MVP of this
movie Rosa Salazar who I don't think
I've ever seen in anything else before
she's phenomenal like I'm astounded at
how good she is in this and yes I
recognized at least a portion of that is
potentially tweaked by CGI animation but
seriously the amount she is able to
convey non-verbally through posture
through looks through just a pause like
a little movement of our mouth leg
there's it's so alive
I almost said it's so subtle it's not
really but it's so finely tuned because
when when you're when an actor plays a
character who is gonna be this heavily
CGI augmented
you can often end up with one of two
things much actually much in the same
way as what can happen when a character
has a lot of prosthetic makeup
oftentimes you can either end up with an
actor who just gets buried under the
effects and you don't see much
performance which actually unfortunately
does happen with some of the supporting
characters or you end up with someone
who is trying to force their acting
through the through the effects and they
end up being over-the-top and campy and
ridiculous
she rides the line perfectly everything
comes through but it does not feel
forced or over-the-top she was
mesmerizing like instantly the instant
her character opens her eyes those big
eyes which I got used to very quickly
she communicates so much just with a
look just with an expression just with
taking a pause she conveys so much
thought process and it's it's we I'm
serious this is an astounding
performance and I move and I really feel
like it's not gonna end up getting the
recognition it deserves partly because
of the CGI augmentation probably because
the movies not being as successful at
the box office as I think probably I'm
gonna end up wishing it was but though
she cares this movie handily as far as
the other performers go I don't know the
actor who plays Hugo who's sort of the
teenage boys somewhat romantic II and
just I'll avoid spoilers as best as I
can if I think I have to go there I'll
warn you don't worry so Hugo's quite
good again he's got really good
chemistry with Aleta so that's the main
thing that needs to work there you've
got um Jennifer Connelly and Marshall Al
Ahly as some supporting characters and I
mean they bring a little bit because
they're both do performers I think my
Hershel ollie
in particular you know brings a little
bit extra into playing the world of
vector but
there isn't a lot to those parts I mean
there isn't really a lot in the manga
either so I don't want to be like oh
they got it wrong well no because the
manga very much focuses on Aleta in Edo
as the film does as well I mentioned
that there are some performances that
kind of get lost in the effects I think
the big one is Jackie Earle Haley who
plays sort of this I forget what they
called him because some of the names are
a little bit different from what I'm
used to from from the manga so I cannot
I keep forgetting what they called him
but he's the he's big hulking thing and
just he's he gets buried under the
effects he just doesn't come through his
performances is too subtle it's too
naturalistic and it doesn't read
especially considering that for some of
the moments to be is cathartic as they
are intended to be he needs to be more
intimidating than he is and part of it
is that a much better performance from
supporting sort of CGI augmenting
character is a IDI screen playing one of
the bounty hunters he's he's quite good
I like him anyway I he has a very
strange kind of charisma to him it's
hard for me to put my finger on but I
find I find him really hard to look away
from I've always liked him ever since
like you know saw him back on Game of
Thrones as the original Daario naharis
he was way better than the second guy
they got to and it was so he's quite
good and the effects in general are very
good and let and I suppose that brings
us to Rodriguez and what he brings to
this he brings a fantastic flow to these
action scenes and also just great the
whole thing looks great but again it's
kind of bolstered by elitist performance
because like she's the way that she
looks you're stepping out from from
waking up for the first time and
stepping out into a city built on
garbage but looking around with such
wonder
and you can with no words you can tell
from our performance that she's seeing
the beauty in this and it's shot in a
way that like yeah I guess it is all
kind of cool but then also at later
times when it needs to feel dark and
dingy dangerous and dirty it absolutely
does while still feeling like the same
place and Robert Rodriguez does great
work in terms of the the action scenes
the pacing of them is great the
choreography of them is great the way
that they're shot it never gets too
fancy and there's some very hectic
action but I always knew what was going
on the hits even though it is ultimately
nine times out of ten it's pixels
hitting pixels the hits felt impactful
they felt like the hit they felt like
they hurt and that was that was a big
thing and you know given how
action-heavy this is that's that's a big
thing that needed to work and it
absolutely does and I think in an odd
way it kind of makes me annoyed that
Rodriguez spent so long sort of
basically working out of his garage you
know a lot of stuff that he did was he
built his own sort of personal special
effects studio which is why a lot of his
special effects were so cheap and wonky
but it gave him complete control so to
see him work with you know basically
special effects a la James Cameron and
realize oh god you know if you hadn't
like sort of insisted on being able to
do everything in your backyard you we
could have gotten some amazing looking
stuff out of you but I'm glad we got it
now but there are some issues like the
main problem with the thing is
ultimately narrative Lee because if
you're familiar with the manga it's
pulling bits and pieces from about the
first three volumes or so of the manga
so the result is a bit of an
undisciplined story it doesn't focus in
as much as it really kind of needed to
in order to land strictly speaking as a
narrative the result is is almost
picaresque in terms of how it feels like
little samplings of of things but none
of them
are the main thrust of the story because
we've got stuff worked in here with
Aleta's past and history and origins
which is speaking personally is the
first thing I would have cut I mean also
because like I find it the least
interesting part of the manga - like I
am fascinated by what she's doing now
where she came from I honestly don't
really care so at anytime the thankfully
it doesn't eat up a lot of screen time
but anytime that comes up like Izone
doubt a bit but in terms of overall
pacing so like the the first three
volumes of the manga again trying not to
get into spoilers on it deals initially
with Aleta becoming a bounty hunter
second volume deals heavily with her
relationship with Hugo and third volume
deals primarily with the sport of motor
ball so this has all three of those and
what I mean in like what it feels on
disciplines so they have Aleta register
as a bounty hunter which is something
you know she said she wanted to do so
Sally comes out of nowhere but she does
that there's an action scene not long
after that we never actually see her a
hunter bounty like ever not even once
not even a montage of it and next thing
we know she's in tryouts to compete in
motor ball so that's what I mean when I
say there's a lack of discipline and
they were probably trying to cram in a
few too many narrative threads for this
thing I think I think the motor ball was
something to push to a sequel of course
I say that but at the at the same time
it's very obviously that they were
trying to set up some stuff for the
sequels largely having to do with
allusions to a bigger villain that is
ultimately gonna be dealt with later
although I will say we had got way ahead
glimpses of this character at a few
points and I had not recognized who was
playing the character until the very end
of the movie I went oh okay that's kind
of cool
but I just unfortunately unless the
the overseas box-office really blows it
away this is probably not gonna get a
sequel so it does annoy me that it ends
on a bit of uh on a bit of a cliffhanger
whereas I think you know either taking
an ending note more from the first
volume or the second volume of the manga
either more sort of the the triumphant
warrior or a more kind of melancholy
tone either one of those would have
worked but it tries to have both at the
same time whilst also setting up a
sequel and it doesn't quite pull
together it doesn't fall apart but sort
of after about the halfway point the
narrative starts to lose steam because
it kind of loses focus a bit and it's
just it it just didn't know which bits
of these three volumes to trim out and
because I suspect the reason that both
about the hyundai and the motor baller
and there is for the variety of the
action scenes and they are both great
action scenes do not mistake me on that
but I just I don't know if from a
narrative perspective if it was worth it
for that so whether or not this is worth
it for you to rush out and see in the
theater or whether it's a bit more of a
way to watch it at home I think depends
on what elements you really want to work
if you want good strong main characters
I which I do believe this has their
dynamic is great I and like I found the
relationship between IDO and and I leave
it to basically be perfect that was
exactly what I wanted as relationships
so I'm really happy as a result in that
the action is really good but if you are
narrative focused if you need the story
to sort of end in a satisfying and like
everything feels complete kind of way
your you may end up walking away a
little bit irritated and I don't think
that's a spoiler to say that it just
kind of it doesn't really end so much as
it stops um but not like in a hard to be
continued way you know it's not matrix
reloaded or anything like that but you
know that that that unfortunately is is
a bit of a bummer that it loses steam as
it goes along but I still really enjoyed
it I'm glad I saw it so Elita battle
angel you seen it what did you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it whole bunch of stuff that
to do down there as well because there's
buttons links patreon hey I appreciate
it
plus other stuff to check out besides
you know give it a look it's all down in
the description or don't that's okay too
because at the end of the day you're the
council I'm just running the meetings
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]